hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday May 16th 2016 how's it going how
are ya how's you like are you liking
your life are you enjoying your life do
you hate your life would you like to
make a change well fortunately there's a
solution with my new seven part
eight-track tapes I'll help you turn
around your life by making me a rich
[ __ ] first thing you do anyways
I am in a great [ __ ] mood it's
actually Sunday when I'm recording it
when I'm recording this it's Sunday and
I got the [ __ ] baby juices are
flowing blood is flying through my
system right now heart rate is [ __ ]
wonderful you know what because I worked
out the last two [ __ ] days in a row
and my brand-new Jairaj [ __ ] my new
[ __ ] gym it's finally done I went
back and I picked up my my truck you
know my own [ __ ] Ford truck that I
had a in storage while they finished it
they did a phenomenal [ __ ] job i
outfitted the whole thing with a bunch
of rogue fitness [ __ ] and I never
[ __ ] show you my house I might have
to make a video I might have to show
it's a little [ __ ] chips a little
cute chip I'll give you a before and
after you know I might even wear my leg
warmers for you I'll give you a quick
[ __ ] two second tour the goddamn
thing I got my atomic holds up top and I
got to tell you old freckles old
freckles lost a lot a lot of what little
he had holy [ __ ] I went onto the
pegboard I felt like you know the fort
yelling first time you ever try to do a
pull-up in your life it's like it feels
like you were born without those muscles
because you never use them you know what
I mean not like you go oh what's on top
of the fridge you know what are you
doing you jump up and down use your cash
you know grab the top of it and [ __ ]
pull yourself up you little stupid feet
squeaking on the front of the [ __ ]
wheel and you try to go up which is
by the way and if you ever made a video
of it you put it on YouTube I'm sure
there would be hundreds of thousands of
comments saying that it was an epic fail
refrigerator pull-up because people like
when you fail you know why because they
don't like themselves anyways so it's
done and I'm so [ __ ] just like of
course there's a few little doodads we
got to do Nia wants an elliptical in
there you know which is [ __ ]
hilarious three because she could give a
rat [ __ ] ass about this gym and still
until it started coming together and now
she loves it you know but what's great
is it's the garage and everybody knows
that the woman the wife the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] lady over there everybody knows
that they get the house but the guy gets
the garage and see the women think that
they win because they got the [ __ ]
house right you don't want the house the
houses were all the responsibilities the
house is where the bills come to the
house is where the [ __ ] people knock
on the door and the cops come they go to
the [ __ ] house nobody nobody goes to
the garage the garage is [ __ ] it's
genius you know you act like it's a
[ __ ] um we go out to the garage well
I can't get out of the house they don't
give a [ __ ] you go in and garage it
that's it and she's got no [ __ ] idea
you wait till I get one of those little
[ __ ] kegerators out there we doing
keg stands as I did curls right taking
in calories as I burn them off at the
same time while getting shit-faced this
new exercise video that I'm going to be
putting out you know I don't know what I
would call it
we need alliteration right drunk dips or
some [ __ ] like that right just to get
people to buy alcoholic aerobics that's
too wordy - not to worry - two syllable
II I don't know whatever I'll brainstorm
on it you know all you got to do is just
have a [ __ ] headband on and people
will buy the video if you promise them
you're going to help them out right you
have a [ __ ] headband on they spray a
little fake sweat on you and you know
all you're going to get is a couple of
hotties behind you just smiling and [ __ ]
right the very least somebody can jerk
off to it
right the next thing you know they start
flying off the [ __ ] shelves and then
what do you do yet you add on to the
garage add on the garage I've told you
guys forever my dream [ __ ] house
and my dream house I don't even know
what the house looks like I just know
what the garage looks like the garage
don't you see as my dad loved to say the
garage don't you see would be a three
car garage right one for me one for her
and the other for whatever my old
[ __ ] truck all right and then
upstairs they all there being upstairs
the upstairs would have a gym and have a
drum room and a [ __ ] cigar bar slash
[ __ ] sports bar that's what it would
be okay one door in one door out maybe a
[ __ ] the ladder to go up onto the
roof to buy you right and that's I think
if every [ __ ] guy had that there's no
[ __ ] way you couldn't be a happily
married man because you just could be in
the house you got your kids running
around everybody's freaking the [ __ ] out
you know I need a break I want to be
[ __ ] single you know without the Luas
I just want to [ __ ] just sit and
drink without you [ __ ] people in my
what's left of my hair that's where the
upstairs comes in and then you just go
up there you have a great time while you
slowly kill yourself you know and then
with every cigar your smoke and every
drink you have you know that you're one
close one step closer to death which is
a great thing because it's a relief you
know and I started off happy it got a
little dark edge with you you wouldn't
know that I'm a happily married man by
saying all that stuff but I also am by
nature I am a [ __ ] loner and you know
I guess you know I'm just feed to get
away from people every once in a while
and um do that would be the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know have a couple of cool [ __ ]
dogs those dogs that [ __ ] lay around
and like the howl you know like a
[ __ ] blood out
right just sit there watching the game
getting hammered
you know soundproof walls you can't hear
your family you just fitting in there
they once in a while you look over your
[ __ ] bloodhound a rusty rusty put a
dogwood bar with join with you yeah yeah
you [ __ ] get it you [ __ ] get it
right I hope you enjoyed that because
that's fantasy now man I that's it right
there you know I don't know whether some
people want the White House some people
want a [ __ ] Oscar and then some
people just want would like to be able
to get a tan and have a two-story
[ __ ] garage that's it
you know I'm part of that third group
part of the third group everybody so
anyways I [ __ ] went down there used
all that rogue fitness [ __ ] that I
bought and like I said you know these
guys are not paying me or anything like
that they actually sent me those
colorful wigs now I don't know what the
[ __ ] to do with them because I have more
weight than I need so I got some
stand-up shows coming up in the LA area
if you're building a [ __ ] gym you
know and I don't like how do I make just
a fair contest I don't [ __ ] know if
you build in a gym and you listen to the
podcast and you want some colorful
plates some weights I got them because I
was going to take it over to play it
again Sam I'm plating in sports whatever
the [ __ ] they are but they just so
goddamn and Celtic you know what I mean
if you think that bald-headed [ __ ] on
the the pawnshop show how we just
[ __ ] you go in then imagine you got a
bar of gold and the guys like yeah
you know how much you want for this
you're like well the market value is
[ __ ] whatever you know I could 1200
ollars an ounce why don't you give me
give me a thousand and out anything see
what do you really want for it what I
want to [ __ ] smash it over go [ __ ]
yourself like what a [ __ ] business
people coming in selling their old
[ __ ] hair dryers you know they're
asked out right and you've got a [ __ ]
take as much out of that crack as you
can I get you know what's your business
I'm going too hot in that guy god bless
them god bless all right so played
against sports it's the same [ __ ] way
you'll come in with something with the
price tag still on it yeah I'll give you
like a dollar fifty you know what I mean
it's just like you mean they make
Richard Rollins look like a statement I
[Music]
mean these [ __ ] guys bust you down so
bad it's like whatever you're selling
them is like how about I give it to you
for free but I get to hit you over the
head with it first how about that
don't give me any [ __ ] money I might
I just mush it right in your [ __ ] jaw
I'm not doing that so I would rather
give it to a podcast listener for free
but I'm not shipping these [ __ ]
things it's like I don't know what it is
I think it's 2 45 pound plates 235 I
don't know what it is they're [ __ ]
big and the heavy that's all I know
whatever it's free free weights though
anyways um went down there yesterday I
did [ __ ] chest and try today I did
the upper body stuff all the body weight
[ __ ] Nia wanted the speed bag which I
thought was a little [ __ ] stupid you
know what I mean I always hated the
speed bag unless you really train for a
fight the enemy doo-doo-doo-doo then you
go your [ __ ] cubicle that always
seems so it just seems [ __ ]
disrespectful to people actually fight
for a [ __ ] living like the level of
respect that I have for people that do
that for a [ __ ] living just the
[ __ ]
courage it takes to do that but of
course now it's up there and I'm down
there what did he get that boys are
diplomatic but what did the data double
get that that's [ __ ] that it updated
that denim go at it so now of course now
I'm going to get [ __ ] obsessed with
that [ __ ] I don't know what it's going
to do for me
I'm hoping it's going to bring my
freckles out you know anyway speaking of
fights did anybody watch UFC you're up
street fighting
not in the red corner did anybody see
the UFC 168 eight eight eight was
basically I think the USA or the world
versus Brazil and I think Brazil once
again proved that they you know you want
to [ __ ] get into a fight slash be in
the missionary position with another
person if you think you're coming out on
top and it happening they pretty much
they pretty much dominated the [ __ ]
night but except for this one guy and
I'm not going to know the names and
actually tweeted the guy I'm still not
good members naming is a very [ __ ] a
unique name and was [ __ ] he's
fighting this guy this guy's making all
these silly faces when he's going and
they're going like the Brazilian dude I
guess he was a champion or he is a
champion that's right he's a champion
and then he [ __ ] that G it's great
that was having a few when I was
watching this he's [ __ ] with he can
suck it he was a champion and he was
supposed to fight he got hurt so we want
to make sure he's on a percent so he's
coming down he's making all these chili
faces and [ __ ] I just remember the
announcers going like walking I was like
the biggest fighting pattern for years
me making faces that camera's not even
nervous right all of this [ __ ] right and
then it comes to [ __ ] white - he
[ __ ] you know old Dudley do-right
he's got a police officers haircut you
like this guy could have been a state
trooper and he's [ __ ] comment down
and I'm like I well let's see what's
going to go on here the white dude seems
to be in a little better shape the
Brazilian guy surprisingly for a
champion has a little bit of a dad but
you know what I mean and whatever they
start going at it and you know white
boys take it a little bit he's giving it
bag he's taking it whatever then all of
a sudden the Brazilian guy starts just
running at him and he [ __ ] each one
and it get any regroups he starts
running man again this [ __ ] guy the
white through what the [ __ ] state
trooper haircut he's backing up and as
he's backing up he gives them just a
little [ __ ] little right there Fred
with the [ __ ] a right look right
well back
and this [ __ ] guy just he just shut
up this guy's hard drive he just [ __ ]
Peppa that guy look just right now like
a controlled implosion
you know when they take down a [ __ ]
building and everybody for some reason
can take off work to go down and watch
it you know that's what they waste a
sick day on like is any way I could
breathe in that [ __ ] recall that [ __ ]
not asphalt oh Christ what the [ __ ] do
you call that [ __ ]
asbestos right they could breathe it in
anyway he [ __ ] just hit the guy I
can't just caught him the right way me
granite if he hit me with that I mean I
would have been dead there'd be no
podcast ever again you know but he just
caught the guy I guess right and the guy
just went right like a ton of bricks he
[ __ ] went down and the [ __ ] white
dude just lost it you know he just
[ __ ] he runs over to his quarter
climbs I better gonna get on the fence
he went right up and over hug his Hulk
and just kept screaming I'm a [ __ ]
world champion it was awesome
also I just blew out your isn't it was
[ __ ] awesome I got this - I think
it's blew out my [ __ ] ear it was just
fun to see somebody like that excited
and then of course they said that he was
from Cleveland so I tweeted out
Cleveland finally won a champion
championship and that's why I think
that's why I tweeted out or something
like that but congratulations to that
guy who I can't put I don't not going to
butcher his [ __ ] name it was awesome
to see him win a championship it's great
for the city of Cleveland right and even
though it wasn't a team sport you know
if you're in Cleveland you got to be
yell well you won't be thinking this
because you guys you know you've been
beaten you've been beaten down by the
sports gods for so long but you guys
really you're afraid of having hope but
I remember reading about Christopher
Columbus when he came over to the
Americas which he thought was I don't
know India I don't want to [ __ ] it up
before he got to land it was a couple of
branches before he got the land and he
started either you know being nice to
people are chopping off people's hands
because they wouldn't give them their
gold fillings depending on what movie
you
you know I always love that new study
find it's like when a [ __ ] was this
information was it wasn't on a cocktail
napkin and somebody finally looked at it
huh did you find one of those scrolls
was it written by somebody hey by the
way this is what really happened
somebody just kept it for years and they
just let the lie go and go and go and
then fall maybe maybe the people that
survived what he did
they had this [ __ ] written down I don't
know I think I'm truckin way off track
here where the hell am i oh yeah so
anyways he eat away before he [ __ ] got
to land Andy that was a halfway decent
guy or an absolute [ __ ] war criminal
depending on what you believe either way
don't you get the day off you know
sometimes people got to die to get a
[ __ ] day off you know when you really
think about it anyways the [ __ ] was I
talking about yeah you take some [ __ ]
branches and [ __ ] so there you go what
guy from Cleveland is a champion all
right it starts with one so now you got
to be looking at the Cavaliers I don't
think they've lost yet it's funny
everyone in Cleveland right now is going
shut up you're gonna [ __ ] all right I'll
shut up just say it
that's another weird city part of me
once Cleveland to win but there's just
such a hilarious misery to the Cleveland
sports fan I almost want to see it keep
going so I guess I'm going to be happy
either way I was really surprised that
OKC beat beat the Spurs considering I
never watched I just watch the Celtics
but I was hoping that I was hoping that
Tim Duncan was going to get his sixth
wink you know just so I'd have yet
another thing to say to [ __ ] Laker
fans when they bring up Kobe Bryant well
another guy during Kobe's time he won
six he was a team player that one he
really fooled the ball around got
everybody involved didn't need [ __ ]
90 million free agents to come in and
help them out every [ __ ] year all
right sorry anyway let's plow ahead here
what am I talking about here so yes so
congratulations and I was disappointed
with the cyborg fight you know what I
mean
I was sitting there going like yeah I
know I want to see this chick fight I
want to see you know and you know and I
tell you the women's rights are usually
better than the men I don't know why
they go out it's like they go in it like
[ __ ] alley cat it's crazy I just
don't understand how they can just how
you can just kick somebody and with your
bare foot and it doesn't hurt you to you
know they should [ __ ] have just
regular people like me just go in and do
mm-hmm
after the first strike punch once with
your hand [ __ ] you know you put in under
your armpit anyways but she fought some
[ __ ] she was like eight six and one so
I'm like what the [ __ ] she's going to
destroy it this is going to be over in
the first round and then lo and behold
Jesus she [ __ ] hits hard she [ __ ]
which is rain and punches and the other
woman was was you know who's getting who
was doing way better than I was one jab
and I would have been on my back but she
was [ __ ] eat them for well for a
minute and then she went down and then
there was a moment when she was always
moving but it looked like she was out
and the guy stopped the fight right
which he should I think was right to
stop the fight through in the end when
they have the official decision they cut
to her right and everybody cheers she's
Brazilian it's the hometown crowd and
when they cut to the other the woman who
lost she's like holding back tears and
she's just looking up it's why I love
this fighter forever she was just
looking up at the [ __ ] the diamond
vision thing whatever the big screen and
she waited she was on the scoreboard the
second she was on the scoreboard she
just goes and the whole place Buddha
she was so [ __ ] mad which is
understandable I mean I can't imagine
train in that [ __ ] long and that
goddamn hard and then it's just over in
like three minutes it must have been
brutal but uh I don't know she was grad
she was all heart so hopefully she'll
come back or that matter I was really
into that last one and that Cleveland
guy was hilarious he was he was talking
every like you know and I know everybody
here you don't like me because we're in
Brazil but you guys make this point
great you call them out on it you know
you're not voting for me because I'm a
[ __ ] that's because I'm from
Cleveland he should've been but I'm from
Cleveland I'm usin it anyways let's see
here I don't know if I have any
advertising here hang on one second in
the meantime I'll tell you a quick story
you guys are all well aware that the
Virginia's Prince died did you guys see
that
do you get that in your paper so anyways
out here in Beverly Hills they're having
an auction on one of his guitars the
yellow one that he did oh how many
[ __ ] times I got typing my [ __ ]
password come on
because I can't [ __ ] remember it like
that [ __ ] it up again third time to
June at the hum wood it is already [ __ ]
it up
imagine being this dumb and actually
[ __ ] having your own gym kind of
dangerous isn't it all right so he
they're auctioning off one of his
guitars was the one to be used with the
new power generation the cream album I
believe and somebody bought it a few
years ago I can't believe it was even
for sale to some guitar collector
admittedly doesn't play him he just
collects them
he paid 30 grand for this [ __ ] thing
so he says I should read this word for
[ __ ] word this is so [ __ ]
priceless
he and he says like the reason why he's
selling it is because you know it's
become you know with the passing of
prints it's become so valuable
daddy's actually nervous to have it he's
nervous to own the [ __ ] thing right
which [ __ ] it let's just like dude why
don't you just say you know what the
guy's [ __ ] just died everybody's
paying attention this is a great time to
sell this [ __ ] guitar I'm trying to
make money off of this guy's death but
can't you just say that you know I areas
Prince's guitar all right I got to
really discuss it it's just a way a
member there's nothing wrong with it you
want to make a buck just you know the
guy died and I'm trying to make [ __ ]
money off of it all right
bah bah yellow car face goes I've been a
prince fan since I was a little kid and
that guitar always stuck out to me
because it was super cool and stylish
said the current owner paid about 30
grand for it he said unfortunately as
morbid as it is when people pass their
items become more valuable I think
something is valuable this could be too
risky to continue to have in my
possession he's worried about his safety
keep the [ __ ] out of him and you try to
make some money trying to make it
you try to make some money that's so
[ __ ] creepy it's a really
cool-looking guitar but I don't think I
could own a guitar of a dead person who
was way better at playing than I'll ever
be I feel like that should be in like
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame so people
can just go and look at it stay in your
house how [ __ ] weird would that be
just having people over and people going
is that it yeah that's printed guitar I
would immediately be whispering to my
wife going this guy [ __ ] killed let's
get out of here
[ __ ] if he of us could talk it
immediately creeped me out but that's me
you know I'm paranoid son of a [ __ ] she
wants a [ __ ] two-story garage
assuming do I not have any [ __ ] reads
this week I think I'm out of advertisers
I don't know if you guys have noticed
but I've slowly but surely pissed all of
them off
no well well maybe maybe I do have some
advertising you just hasn't sent it
nope I'm hitting the refresh button I
don't [ __ ] see it now you know what
why are they so censor don't they
understand that if I [ __ ] on it you guys
actually listen to it and then maybe
you'll buy it as opposed to just
fast-forwarding through all of it that's
what I try to do I'm just you know I'm
trying to help them make money right now
what the [ __ ] you going to do about
speaking of guitars you know I played
for about five six years and then I
stopped over the last couple years when
the downstairs was being redone and then
I recently got back into it but you know
this is the deal I play drums I [ __ ]
around a guitar and I've always wanted
one of those lemon bursts [ __ ] uh Les
Paul's I'm trying to find one a
left-handed one I just think it's
[ __ ] I don't know but you know what
kills me whenever I get to get a guitar
especially a Les Paul I just start
thinking of all the [ __ ] great music
I've I've heard coming out of that thing
and then when I pick it up it's just
like oh Jesus
am I the [ __ ] that just bought a
[ __ ] guitar he doesn't deserve I
think I um
alright I'm going to pause here just so
I can just [ __ ] if I get advertising
later I can just put it in here or maybe
not so maybe it don't see let's see what
happens all right pausing here for some
advertising that might be read later all
right I'm back did I read anything I
don't know I guess I'll find out later
anyway so it's only for 27 year Pacific
Coast time and in 33 minutes the Blues
San Jose shaft [ __ ] game starts and I
can't tell you how [ __ ] excited I am
about this and I already know how
they're probably going to sell this game
it's a tale of toasting two cities that
have never gotten over the they're fans
have had more heartbreak than a [ __ ]
blue balloon [ __ ] spear to the chest
it was great
for one city they'll be moving on to the
Stanley Cup final not finals as I always
say the Stanley Cup final and for the
other team more misery when neither one
should be ashamed
they both knocked off between the two of
them the two perennial Giants in the
West with the LA takes on the [ __ ]
Chicago Blackhawks I think I do some
[ __ ] like that somebody is going to make
it to the Stanley Cup final I hate that
it's the final I like the finals I hate
people whose only one people will be
boots the NBA play up to seven games the
finals right I'd have no problem with
that plural that's a great thing you
know when people go like yeah all those
[ __ ] over there in Europe or around the
world go why do you call it football
yeah ours makes sense it's football and
somebody goes I do you want to be
technical you should call it feet ball
you using both your feet what you call
football there you go you dribble right
back and forth between your feets
they're much called people feeding balls
[ __ ]
it's called [ __ ] in other words once
you go [ __ ] yourself um anyways I am
really excited about this and what I
would like to do don't you see is I
would like to have one of my giant ice
cubes with some [ __ ] booze and
because I booze hard in the weekends
because I [ __ ] stare at a goddamned
script all week before I come home and
boost hard who's getting to my drinking
is out of control I think this is why
people have children at some point in
our life because if you don't you just
drink yourself to death I'll tell you
it's fun what's funny than [ __ ] diapers
um anyways I am uh I'm nervous about
this one I'm nervous I had a belief that
the Blues were going to get by the
blackhawks
I'm not getting almost surprised and I
had a belief that they could give by the
Dallas Stars and certainly with the
goaltending issues which I didn't even
know they [ __ ] had it's still 1:7 so
I figured this one it makes sense that
you get to the next each time you get a
little blood tested so I want to say
whoever wins this is going to [ __ ]
win the Stanley Cup in the standing Cup
Stanley Cup Finals
but I was hanging out with bartnik last
night and he knows more about hockey
than I know about myself and he was
saying that he thinks Tampa Bay
Lightning you know that goaltender went
down so we shall see I'm sticking with
the Blues me me a lowly meet me at the
fair I'm sticking with the Blues that's
my team and because my real team the
Bruins didn't make it by still love them
or beat again in October and if they
play the Blues I'm not going to give a
[ __ ] if they beat him [ __ ] whatever
12 to nothing I won't give a [ __ ]
speaking of which somebody sent me
something about you know people always
love to make points on all the dumb [ __ ]
that I say on Twitter like I mean how
many times do I have to admit that I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that you really don't need
to correct me I realized that I'm an
idiot but somebody goes think there's
not a lot of scoring and soccer and
sends me like one day's worth of [ __ ]
scores it's just like okay well if you
average it out I think I'm right you
know you know what's funny about that
[ __ ] Leicester City championship do
you know they found out that they wanted
championship because two other teams
played to like a 1-1 tie there wasn't
even a playoff playoff there wasn't even
a [ __ ] playoff like here we go
this is it we're down to the final two
[ __ ] teams we're going to play for 19
hours and hopefully at some point
somebody's going to put the [ __ ] ball
in the net and the goal whatever and
then it's going to be over except it's
going to be injury time that nobody
knows what it is except for the [ __ ]
the reps everybody starts whistling I
didn't even have that they watched these
two other teams play to a tie and then
everybody went crazy that seems really
anti-climactic to me I think you want
somebody [ __ ] kick the ball it goes
into the [ __ ] net somebody scores
right then collectively as sports fans
you all [ __ ] bust your nut when it
goes in yeah I just punch of people
walking around in scarves watch somebody
wouldn't get a [ __ ] tie and then
you're excited about that I I don't get
that
you know you would think that a country
that survived a [ __ ] blitzkrieg like
that level of excitement and your [ __ ]
life you think you think that your
sports would reflect it maybe you hadn't
maybe your [ __ ] grandparents had
enough [ __ ] excitement for one
lifetime
annual lifetime too so they just started
watching that I don't know or maybe I
don't understand enough about the game
and I'm just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
maybe that's what it is no I have no
idea whatever go go get some [ __ ]
fish and chips and go [ __ ] yourself
alright let's let's read some mom let's
read some some of this [ __ ] here I
got from this week oh by the way I had a
great weekend down and not before I get
to this I got an hour to film so don't
worry about I had a great weekend live I
just been in a real slump as far as
writing new bits just because my life
has ground to a halt here it's like you
know I'm not going out I'm not doing
anything like my wife went to the
Beyonce concert last night at the Rose
Bowl and I was actually thinking I
should have gone because there's no
[ __ ] way I wouldn't got a bit out of
that I would have felt old it would have
felt stupid I wouldn't know the songs
when she come out [ __ ] whippin a
weave around and [ __ ] maybe something I
could talk about right but instead I
went down to the comedy store I did a
couple of shows and I actually went out
there's a lot of comedians are out there
and I was just so [ __ ] sick of doing
the same [ __ ] and trying to make it work
I just
everyone's want to just go out there and
you just not thinking anything and you
just start [ __ ] talking
it works way better and it breathes new
life into all your jokes I just kind of
went out there and which is a very
terrifying thing to do when you've never
done that in standup because you really
feel like you're you know remember in
like the matrix
when Keanu Reeves they're trying to
convince him to [ __ ] and step off that
building and he's not going to fall to
his death all he has to do with bully
isn't was it that movie or was it
[ __ ]
battlestar galactica Moonraker i don't
know what the phone of those space
movies right
it wasn't even space but sci-fi he had
to like believe it if you believe it
then you find if you if you don't
believe it you actually fall to your
death this is sort of one of those
things but of course you're not going to
die you're just going to you know
metaphorically die on stage is his basic
stepping off the building is basically
just leaving your act behind and just
[ __ ] just talking so I just went out
there and I just started riffing on the
fact that I made a smart move by not
going to Beyonce because you know when I
went to Lady Gaga with my wife you know
I [ __ ] I mean she was mad at me for
like three [ __ ] days after that one
in defensively which there really really
is no defense
I watched the Patriots we lost I think
to the Ravens and the playoffs during
the day so I was already drinking I
already have a good six-pack in me and
then we took a car service to [ __ ]
Lady Gaga and we went on to thing and it
was it you know I'm all about seeing the
band I want to see the drummer and all
that type of [ __ ] and she on this tour
for whatever reason her towards her
choice whatever she had him in like this
house it was a [ __ ] house and I
couldn't see the drummer it was like a
window I could kind of see his hands a
little bit a little bit of his head and
that was it and was just like [ __ ] I
want to see the band and I can't was so
long gone I mean what the [ __ ] but I
just started telling that story how I
[ __ ] pissed her off and then if I
went to Beyonce thing you know how I
would I would just you know you know
when they sang like that independent
woman song and everything just the dirty
looks like be given most of the women
there knowing that they were full of
[ __ ] that they shouldn't be putting
their hands up in the air you know it
was just just smart move that I didn't
go and my wife still has never gotten
over my behavior at the Lady Gaga
concert to the point that I actually
asked her to come on the podcast to talk
about the Beyonce concert
she just goes no and I tried not to
laugh I tried to hold it together I go
what do you mean no she goes we think
I'm a [ __ ] idiot now she goes I'm not
going on the podcast and give you giving
you an opportunity to start trashing
beyond saying I'm not gonna trash beyond
say okay I have to admit she started
showing me video clips of the concert
and she had it like the way she was told
she was we're on the couch so she
snuggle up next to me so she's holding
the kind of low to my you know near my
stomach and like three times I started
laughing looking at the looking at the
clips and looked I know she's way more
talented than I could ever be I don't
even though we put on a show like here
but this is just something funny to me
about when everybody dances in unison
and they had that you know that angry
look on their face it's just the
funniest flips just like what is your
what is the problem and coming up they
got their arms out you know and they're
doing that little [ __ ] thing with
their head and their feet are running I
just I can't and I can't even dance like
the [ __ ] nervous me to laugh at it
but it always strikes me it's just it's
absolutely ridiculous something if I
understand why it's awesome and people
appreciate it but it's also really
[ __ ] funny to me I should say I don't
know why I you know I'm just a [ __ ]
don't listen to me so whatever so I made
a great [ __ ] move by not going to
that concert they are very smart married
a couple of years getting wise in my old
I just was just like you know what I can
that's that's the best when you start
you start to know somebody and yourself
well enough to be like you know what I
see the flight coming you know what I
mean it's actually it's like slipping
punches which I go something else
another reason why I suck at fighting
history you could literally tell me on
Thursday I'm throwing this punch at this
time and you would still not only catch
me with it you dug your hole hand but a
foot or whatever when
I just can't do it I I do but I stink at
it so I saw this flight coming and I was
just like all right now and I gave my
two I might take it away and she took
one of her girlfriends so I look good
with the friends and all of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I avoided a major [ __ ]
flight and I just went onstage because I
was like I'm sick of my jokes that was
the point of the [ __ ] I'm sick of my
jokes so whenever I get into this these
whatever you go writer's block you know
I don't write whatever just written
block I guess I just sort of wing my
[ __ ] I just say to myself what am I
thinking right now what am I feeling and
I was feeling thank God I didn't go to
Beyonce cuz me and my wife would get
into a big fight so and you know it was
funny I didn't even make that decision I
kind of as I was dawn my rear brought me
up with he gives the best [ __ ] intros
he said this [ __ ] enjoy good you know
his next guy come to the stage you know
he never made me laugh you know
immediately people are just dying and
just [ __ ] he just does that stuff but
you know people seem to enjoy him I
don't know I've written a lot of his
stuff and just you know just making me
look like a complete [ __ ] so I went
out there and it wasn't until after I
shook his hand that I was actually
thinking of the first bit I was going to
do and I was just like oh I guess we're
gonna feel like [ __ ] coming out a month
I can't even say it and then I just over
the years of just knowing that trick I
was just like what am I feeling right
now is just I'm failing I'm glad I
[ __ ] did go to Beyonce because I get
to a three-day fight with my wife and I
just started talking about that and it
just it worked and then I had this other
chunk of material and I did the last
joke without even setting it up from the
other [ __ ] and it still worked it just
worked in a different way and it was
just great it may be [ __ ] love stand
up again because I was really not like I
would ever hate standing but just this
whole [ __ ] writing every day alright
alright and now through the magic of
technology is now 10:01
Pacific Coast time and I'm watching the
third period uh st. Louis can Jose I
take the [ __ ] game because I have it
set to go to watch the first two period
two one st. Louis so far all right let's
see these [ __ ] Adam get on with the
[ __ ] launching of the sports here
alright we'll link with everybody over
there you need to know how to cook
unless you got a broad in your life and
she's old schools you know to me not
only do you feel like you know your way
around the kitchen but cooking at home
me eating healthier and saving money
instead of ordering expensive tastes out
all over again but where do you start
blue apron as you covered Rocco for the
last ten less than $10 per meal blue
apron delivers all the fresh ingredients
you need to create home-cooked meals
just follow the easy step-by-step
instructions these meals actually look
really good I wish this was around when
I was a single fella each meal could be
prepared in 40 minutes or less no
overwhelm we trip to the grocery store
no more sad takeout matter how dietary
preferences the manager dietary
preferences blue apron makes it a breeze
to discover and prepare dishes like
seared salmon with asparagus and new
potato hash and creamy aioli right your
own kitchen I don't even know what half
of that is what the [ __ ] is aioli aioli
[ __ ] over you cook with ingredients that
you've never used before like watermelon
radishes Pharaoh farro modal and purple
potatoes and recipes are between 500 and
700 calories per portion delicious and
good for you right now you can get your
first two meals for free at uefa.com
flash fur that's blue a 4.com fresh per
right blue apricot / / a better way to
cook oh here we go me on these me undies
no more sweaty balls will do to me
undies neon do
jeez I'm drinking a makers mark pours
down the pond off my [ __ ] underwear
it dries up real quick and I don't care
my balls are drunken so am i buy these
[ __ ] penny your Queens all right here
nice what are you wearing a suit or what
whether you're wearing a suit or sweat
you spend almost 24 hours a day and your
underwear
unless you're Matthew McConaughey and
then you're aware and you can just run
down the beach carrying a couple of
ferns
whatever the [ __ ] is he goes on up TV so
that's a magazine anyway but instead of
making a statement like Superman's
tights under his everyday clothes your
underwear is probably boring the undies
is here to change that
well you know what Superman's on the
ways pretty boring is it it's just red
you know so you know just [ __ ] name
on it that's going to get this please
include all the following points why
wouldn't I you wrote it I'm going to
read it modal is pronounced modal every
pair of me undies is made from
sustainable modal a prat fabric twice as
soft as cotton allegedly nothing can
describe the fit and the feel of the
undies you got to feel it up against
your balls to appreciate it but once you
try them on you'll understand why
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear if you don't love
your core spare me on these they're free
no questions asked
Mandy says dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear
whether anyone can see them or not
remember Superman it really is like
marketing them clothes towards the
comic-con Crudup they give a [ __ ] about
Superman did he lose the battement
shipping it free in the US and Canada
because you can save up $8 well prepare
with the undies conscription plan gets a
subscription or a single pair it's going
to send off your first order when you go
to the undies soft complex furthest the
undie dust on splash 4 for 20% off your
first order and there we go the final
one legal film five things you can count
on when using legal zones for your
number one more than a million people
have already trusted legal room to help
start their business in corporations
LLC's nonprofits DDA's whatever the [ __ ]
those are and more use legal film to get
started the right way
number two the DOS experience you can
put on Legal Zoom for all this you can
count equals them for all the details
that help they've been helping all types
of businesses owners for over 15 years
number [ __ ] numero tres helpful support
they have the right people standing by
ready to help you with your questions
all based in the United States who shot
fired India number four new model
blackballed legal advice legal room
isn't a law firm so they built a network
of independent attorneys available in 48
states you get answers to your legal
questions and they can review supplier
contracts employment laws and help with
most of the day-to-day situations that
pop up and finally letter B 83 do e
that's the first one
single AA little dos tres Quatro Cinco
seis yet they go to the web a you know I
learned how to contact any Spanish
watching that block right so let me get
knock down they always go oh sure like
you're going to get the [ __ ] up or what
call to action make the smart choice for
your business at legalzoom.com today and
don't forget to enter birth let's check
out the state even more legalzoom.com
alright that's it back to the podcast
your terms of vision let's get to some
questions here for this week uh-oh look
what's back sigh hey oh speaking of
which how great it's on the top Jimmy
[ __ ] little bit oh all right sciatica
hey bill love your podcast I wanted to
tell you about my sister's cure for
sciatica lie but don't was joke I called
the Providence Civic Center
one-night-only Sayaka
my ass [ __ ] she suffered from sciatica
for years three years her doctor
recommended she see a pajama podiatrist
at the foot doctor for all you civilians
out there who filmed her from behind
what a [ __ ] creep as she walked on a
treadmill yeah and with his yoga pants
by the way I don't understand why guys
are [ __ ] so obsessed with yoga pants
I've never been yeah the pants are like
just you know what I took too many yoga
classes I just know what the room smells
like and I just feel like that's what
your clam smells like when you wear
those and I know that's immature I'm
sorry he immediately saw her right foot
was rolling out as she walked he said
this was causing her problems with
sciatica and he made custom orthotic
shoes inserts that she wears most of the
time she said this worked immediately to
completely eliminate her pain from
sciatica she said after you start
wearing the orthotics you should visit a
chiropractor to get everything back in
alignment and you're good to go give it
a try and go [ __ ] yourself thank you so
much for that I don't think I have that
issue but I got the name of a good
chiropractor and you know what god damn
it when I'm uploading this podcast I'm
actually going to go see a doctor
because somebody sent me this thing on
on Twitter go they'll go see a doctor
Jesus did we learn nothing from
so-and-so it was somebody who was on
Letterman who was had a shortness of
breath and he kept blowing it off he
kept talking to people who weren't
doctors and I'm sure you thought I'm
sure you find then he found out it was
[ __ ] lung cancer obviously that's not
what I'm looking at here all right so I
will definitely go thank you for that
all right number two a douche
where will Caitlyn take a [ __ ] this week
number two hi Bill I was a wall and
floor Tyler for 27 years and my go-to
for
lower back pain was a gel ice pack and
lying on a hard floor the gel pack molds
to the area that is sore and the hard
floor keeps your spine flat lie on your
back wait lie on your back on the floor
with your knees bent put the ice now
what does that mean they bend in and
lift them up or just have your feet on
the floor
he put your foot down on the - you jump
up on the wood
sorry thinking about prints now alright
umm then move the ice pack and then try
wait wait wait wait wait I missed the
whole [ __ ] thing it lie on your back
you know what you wrote a bunch of words
that are all like the same I have some
sort of [ __ ] dyslexia can he has like
a bunch of times and feet lie on your
back on the floor with your knees bent
put the ice pack at the spot giving you
trouble leave it there oh I know why he
didn't have any punctuation leave it
there for 15 minutes you can watch TV
doing this then move the ice pack and
then try to feel like you are pressing
your spine into the floor continue with
the treatment once or twice a day until
you feel better I hope this works for
you I love to efforts for family and
reminded me of my childhood and I'm a 57
year old Australian male love the
specials on the podcast hope you get
better soon well that's good to know
via 10 years older than me well that
should work because we kind of age bill
a little bit older than than I was in
1973 or 74 he's about 11 years old
and what you mean he would been would
have been born in 62 so that's right in
your wheelhouse right
you'll probably be born in like what 58
yeah built that's how the math works out
all right cool okay Australian male well
thank you so much for watching and
please tell more people down there in
Australia if you can to check it out I
actually heard a lot of times people say
to put heat on your back I guess it's
better because if you have any sort of
inflammation in the nerve or something
like that I don't know I've been using a
leaf and doing these stretches I feel
much better and I haven't been sitting
down at all I've actually been squatting
like a Vietnamese gambler
and I don't know I that's been working
for me in these stretches I still
haven't quite gotten it better but I'm
going to go to a chiropractor and get
adjusted out Jesus and you know I bet
and I also need glasses finally given in
to that because my every two years when
you're at my advanced age you got to go
get a physical physical I wanna get
physical I got my pilot's license where
you gotta every you know if you're a
younger fella every floor lady lady
every five years you got to renew your
medical you got to get it updated so it
means every two [ __ ] years and I
barely made it through and I'm literally
like what the [ __ ] am I doing here I
don't want to wear glasses I just don't
I just don't want to have another
[ __ ] thing that I have to be with and
I also have this paranoid that all
glasses do is make you [ __ ] eyes
worse
kind of like you know chapstick it just
dries out your lips even more that's
like the big urban myth and then you get
addicted to it then you got to use it
you know whenever I have dry ass lips I
just use a little Vaseline works like a
[ __ ] charm and then I just start
pounding waters and then you're fine you
[ __ ] fine that [ __ ] chapstick and
all that [ __ ] I don't like it I don't
like it makes me have weird dreams you
know get that chemical in their seats
right in your [ __ ] face and it goes
right to your brain next thing you know
you just run it around with an axe and
you drink you ever have a dream like
that some reason you're screaming answer
me
I'm just making this [ __ ] up people I
don't know and what the [ __ ] you want
for me usually that you be advertising
takes up a little bit of time and I
don't have any 4:48 another 12 minutes
and then the game stats oh and I got
another 15 minutes here
[ __ ] well thank you thank God for TiVo
right all right grass killing neighbor
all right fantasy revenge advice hello
billion I'm a 23 year old male I live
with my parents
in the country that even Australia makes
fun oh wow that even Australia makes fun
to from Australians here Oh New Zealand
Wow Jesus I live with my parents in a
country that even Australia makes fun of
New Zealand I don't even a part of a
country I can't read people I love f is
for family and can't wait for season two
thank you so much please tell more
people in New Zealand about it if you
haven't already if he got the time I'm
not trying to put you out you don't
wanna be that douche don't be the douche
but if you do I appreciate it alright so
here we go fantasy revenge advice but
some time ago my father was using a lawn
trimmer on the right side of the front
yard which is only a few feet from our
neighbor's driveway while trimming the
edges of small rock in the grass shot up
and hit our neighbours parked car in the
driveway our neighbor was already at the
front of his house and either saw or
heard the bang and started yelling at my
dad who was apologetic the rock the rock
put a small dent in the car which was
hard to see even close up when I when I
was told what happened my dad buy my dad
I was a little pissed that he yelled but
I knew he had a right to be upset and
although it was an accident
my dad would happily pay for the damages
because he knew he was at fault our
neighbour didn't talk to us again about
a bill or anything so we quickly forgot
about it and moved on a few weeks later
I was at the front of our house that I
saw that the right side of our lawn was
completely dead of foot inwards I
realized this [ __ ] [ __ ] had poisoned
the area of the grass that would usually
cut using the edge trimmer wow this
guy's got major communication issues so
this incident would never happen again
despite my despite my dad telling him
that he would only mow the lawn when the
driveway was empty in the future I asked
my dad if he knew anything and he told
me he had known for a few days but
didn't want to make a big deal about it
my dad is a very easygoing guy who
doesn't get bothered much myself on the
other hand spent the night the next few
nights pana sizing about revenge oh he
looks like you take after your mom
alright get dad's easy-going he married
a [ __ ] hot blooded woman and you know
she calmed it down right and then you
got her [ __ ] DNA all right I like I
like where this is going so far even
though I'm not a big revenge guy your
dad's easygoing it's his house already
my guts saying your dad's easygoing into
[ __ ] house you know don't do anything
to disrupt it because I thought about
doing the exact same thing to his long
but spelling out the words coward
oh my god that's [ __ ] hilarious I
thought about pulling out all of his
plants and dumping it on his car to send
a message it's been a few months and I
still get pissed off when I think about
it
but I decided not to stoop to his level
and pull off a [ __ ] move like that the
only option would be to confront him but
there is no scenario in which that would
end well why not why not why can't you
just next time you see him just say like
dude I got to tell you something I
haven't been on this planet for a long
time so maybe I need to see more [ __ ]
behavior but that's the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] why I don't do that it's
going to I know I would just say hey you
have any idea why this part of the lawn
died isn't that amazing and I would do
that to them every [ __ ] time just do
something to drive them nuts anyway
because I've decided to do nothing and
moved on but it's been about a year and
I'm still thinking about it what would
you have done am i justified to be
pissed this pissed and how the [ __ ] do I
stop myself from letting it get me in
such a bad mood every time I walk past
our front lawn and see the dead strip of
lawn thanks for listening bill come back
to New Zealand
um your lawn is still dead look I'm not
a big on revenge but the great thing
that you have right now is you've waited
a year so if you were to do anything
obviously don't bring any physical harm
to the person he does seem to love that
car that it's just you've why would you
do it why don't you guys read just
replant the [ __ ] grasp
that's what I would do I would replant
the grass this is what you do
replant the grass and get all excited
and then without him knowing what you do
is you set up a [ __ ] video camera all
right
and he just videotape and you try to
catch him doing it that's the best way
to do it right and then he has to
[ __ ] pay for it and then pay for the
previous thing the previous time he
poisoned it like that's what I would do
you know I mean there's obvious things
you could do you could go to a [ __ ]
autozone and buy one of those little
catch trays that captures oil you know
and then when the night you could undo
is [ __ ] let all the oil out of his
car unscrew the thing on the oil pan and
you screw it back up and then he seizes
the edge aligns car you can go that
route you know there's no oil in the
[ __ ] car the key is what you have to
do is he would still figure it out see
if you can't do this all [ __ ] [ __ ]
moves you don't I mean you got to have a
face-to-face thing or what I would do is
I would just repaint replant the grass
and I would set up a [ __ ] video
camera maybe you just say that just say
hey just so you know if you plan on
poison air grasp because I know you're
not a man and you would never say
anything to my dad on my self space you
know I just well you know I got I'm with
security you're going to be on video and
we're going to catch you doing it okay
all right it cost us a lot of money and
I oh my god what in a perfect world
could you just go over and just [ __ ]
just answer the door you go I and you
two right in the nuts
huh you would didn't you just take a
strip of the dead grass me to start
[ __ ] beating his back with it that's
what the [ __ ] you want to do I you know
I actually want to do that right now but
you know what you can't do it you know
what [ __ ] him he did it to you he did it
to you
I'll do you know something I think
you're I think what you came up with is
the best why don't you just write coward
not is anything to do something else to
your dad's house
this guy's a [ __ ] you know what he
doesn't have the balls to confront your
dad so what I think you do yet do the
little coward thing and then set up
video cameras and catch them doing
something else but then you've done
something him it's just it's just awful
it's just this [ __ ] hit for [ __ ]
tat thing I don't know what you have to
do but I feel like something has to be
said at least I know what you do this is
what you do you go down to a [ __ ]
lady shoe store alright and you buy a
cheap pair of [ __ ] women's shoes and
next time you see you wrap it up like a
present and you just give it to and
there's a card in there and everything
and then you do this is what you do you
do that just humiliate the guy and it's
open up and just say hey sweet I just
want to get you you just write from your
heart about what a [ __ ] [ __ ] is and
this is what you do don't ever don't
Kirsten it at all right it really nice
and lovely but you in that without ever
cursing just let them know what an
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] he is for doing
that there you go all that's I think
that you know what I think that's the
winner you know what I might have to I
might have to outsource this to my
listeners if you guys have better ideas
and what to do there nobody gets hurt
you made your point it's [ __ ]
hilarious and that's a funny you know
you tell people that this guy did and
they go through what you do eat em I
went out I went to a ladies shoe store
and I bought them a pair of pumps and
then you get to laugh and every time you
see them just wave you just start
calling them sweetheart give a pet name
maybe you give them a woman's name like
Diane or something just hey Diane how'd
you like the shoes and just every
[ __ ] day you can just do that forever
I don't know it made me feel better
about the situation maybe you can do
that who the [ __ ] knows anyway good luck
with that
but don't do any physical harm or real
property damage that's the brilliance
I'm a said genius pat myself on the back
there sorry about that that that's what
I liked about the last plant is that
you're not hurting him
you write it eloquently you're not
cursing there's nothing he can really do
you just bought them a gift that you
give you give a woman it's perfect you
know I'd send them some candy on
Valentine's Day just I'll just torture
the guy but you just keep giving them
gifts you know no know what else what's
good get him some flat just I don't know
a bunch of [ __ ] like that I don't know
who [ __ ] knows maybe you just do it once
and then that's it and then what you do
and then right after that you replant
the grass and then you just let him know
that you know that he did it he's going
to be too much of a [ __ ] to try to do
it again and then you can tell your dad
years later that that don't tell your
dad that you did it and then years later
you tell them that you did it when you
having a pint you guys can [ __ ] laugh
your balls off all right work argument
hey Bill I work with some real morons
I'm in sales so everyone is a hot-headed
tool really I thought you guys were like
funny it always seemed like the salesmen
Roy's breaking balls and being funny
they all think they're living in a sales
movie oh okay too many Glengarry Glen
Ross all right we have set accounts and
nothing about our job requires us to
generate new business from cold leads
but that doesn't stop these tools so the
other day they're bitching about
Saturday Night Live and how it's not
funny anymore
that's not really a big deal people
always [ __ ] about SNL even when it's
good that didn't bother me but then they
all started saying how they'd be funnier
on the show now Jesus here we go this is
like me me watch now I guess it's not
like that all right let's go Matt expect
me watching UFC being like dude you know
what I wanted done so this is when I
chimed in and told them that
harder than it looks and that they did
not they did not they did have a shot
what and that they did have a shot
although that if you left out a word
there but it's harder than it looks and
if they if they did have a shot having
no stage presence or experience they
would end up freezing up then maybe the
guy who froze up whose face was
everywhere I made the point to them that
if they were offered a spot on SNL
they'd be better to turn it down
they'd have a happier life if they said
no to SNL Jesus do you agree with this
and if you were offered SNL would you
take it do I think that the people on
SNL are funnier than a Salesman yes
absolutely absolutely do I think that
they would freeze up now not necessarily
they would probably you know maybe a few
would freeze up others would get dry
mouth and field plowed through it others
would ham it up you know who knows I
don't know there I they if they offered
me SNL I would know that they were in a
lot of trouble I'm a 48 year old man
next month I I think that they like to
try to get young talent and I think that
window was closed I haven't said that I
got nothing but respected seems like I
haven't just trying to write a [ __ ]
cartoon where we got all the [ __ ]
time in the world to do this [ __ ] where
they have to come out with a brand new
you know ninety minutes - [ __ ]
commercials
what's that 90 - 24 to get technical
eight minutes every half hour that 764
[ __ ] 56 minutes a week [ __ ] you
there's no way I've heard nothing but
that's an absolute it takes a special
personality to be able to do to handle
that and I would actually be worried
about what it would do to my stand-up
career having that level of a commitment
which is why I prefer to do a role in a
movie where it's just sort of like okay
we got you from here to here so it's a
finite thing with that SNL [ __ ] is just
like
I don't know when they started when they
stopped but it just seems to be it's a
hell of a commitment but yeah after they
go did I answer your question to get
offered SNL who says [ __ ] no to that
I don't know I don't know if I get
better
why am I [ __ ] stressing over this it's
not happening but anyway thank you for
sticking up for everybody on SNL I
appreciate that all right
okay here's the last one from a lady
from a [ __ ] lady woman proposing yo
babycakes Billy BER just curious what do
you thought were you what just curious
what your thoughts are sorry everybody
I'm bad at this just curious what your
thoughts are on women proposing love you
thanks for advocating for pit bulls hope
to see you soon please don't use my name
well they never show meaning um I think
that's a bad move on the woman's part I
think you guys generally speaking a more
gung-ho to get married than guys are and
if you propose to a guy and he's too
much of a [ __ ] to say no and then you
end up marrying the wrong person I think
is a woman you should wait for the
[ __ ] guide I think there's a reason
why the guy asked it's because we don't
want to do it so if we are actually
asking then you know you with open eyes
almost of end up and divorced you know
what I don't know I don't lie could be
maybe be kind of cool there's something
cute about it I can tell you that not
talking down to you but uh I saw each
fake proposed to Mia now he throws Gonia
I'm proposing to you right now and she
would always be laughing knowing I was
[ __ ] around and I would always go I
propose that we break up it was a silly
joke and used to always make her [ __ ]
laugh
I don't know she was real cute during
that time when she like wanted me to ask
and I don't know my wife's [ __ ]
adorable so only one may I do took a
special kind of [ __ ] a woman to trick me
into doing this
she didn't trick me anyway that's the
podcast for this week I don't know if I
have any advertising left anymore but
who gives a [ __ ] I never did it for that
anyways right I'll go on go dance for my
supper tonight although I loved it oh I
love that advertising [ __ ] money maybe
I still have it who knows
that's the podcast once again I will try
to take some video this week I actually
made a couple ones but I made one for
verbena maybe one for [ __ ] D del Rey
so it's got their name on it when I
scream and I'll just post those [ __ ]
pigs aren't the [ __ ] move my truck
out again do it anyways that's it that's
the podcast for this week thanks for
listening go [ __ ] yourselves then I'll
check on Thursday let's go blue